الى ماساه انسانيه الان في غزه حيث نقل
مراسل الجزيره في قطاع غزه عن مصدر طبي
قوله انه واحدا 21 شخصا لكم مصرعهم في
حريق دلع في بنايه سكنيه في منطقه تل
الزعتر بمخيم جباليا شمال القطاع
وقالت وزاره الداخليه في قطاع غزه في بيان
مقتضب قالت انها دفعت بقوات كبيره من
طواقم الدفاع المدني والشرطه للتعامل مع
هذا الحادث او هذه الماساه
ينضم الينا من مخيم جباليا الشمالي قطاع
غزه مراسل الجزيره وائل الدحدوح اهلا وائل
وهذه الصور التي وصلتنا قبل قليل نشاهد
فيها حجم الماساه ضعنا في الصوره وائل
حقيقيه
وبالتحديد في الطابق الاخير لهذا المنزل
ويبدو حسب الروايات وشرود العيان المتوفره
في هذه المنطقه لان هذه العائله كانت
تحتفل بقدوم رب الاسره من الخارج بعد ان
اتسمى دراسه الدكتوراه ووصل الى المنزل
وكانوا في حاله احتفال في في هذه العوده
عندما اندلع الحريق
حسب المصادر ذات العلاقه هنا تحدث
داخل البيت كان كما يبدو همم عدد او كميه
من المواد المشتعله في منطقه ما من المنزل
ربما هي التي ساهمت في الاندلاع الكبير
والشام والمفاجاه لعمليه الاحتراف بهذا
المنزل وساهمت ايضا لمنع افراد المنزل من
القدره والاستطاعه على الخروج ومغادره
المن خروج ومغادره المنزل وبالتالي تحولوا
الى ضحايا همم في داخل هذا المنزل
بالتاكيد وحسب المصادر الطبيه هنا
والمصادر وزاره الداخليه تحدث عن اعداد
كبيره همم ما بين قتيل وجريح باصابات خطره
بمعنى ان كل افراد العائله الذين تواجد
ساعه اندلاع هذا الحريق
تحولوا الى ضحايا ما بين وفاه وما بين اا
جريح باصابات خطره لكن حتى الان يرفضون
الادلاء بمعلومات نهائيه على اعتبار ان
طواقم الدفاع المدني والتواقم الشروطيه
والاف من المواطنين في هذه المنطقه ما
زالوا يبحثون في حطام هذا المنزل همم بحثا
عن ربما اشخاص اخرين داخل هذا المنزل لكن
هناك اعداد حقيقه تتردد على السنه بعض
جهات الاختصاص يتحدثون عن عدد كبير يعني
نستطيع القول ان هناك همم نحو 20 ما بين
قتيل وجريح في هذا الحادث المفجع
وبالتاكيد البيت اتت عليه النيران بشكل
كامل والتهامته بشكل كامل همم ما بين
دقيقه واخرى يمكن ان تعقد جهات الاختصاص
هنا مؤتمر صحفيه في مكان الحريق
الكبير هنا في مخيم جباليا همم ارى امامي
قائد الشرطه الفلسطينيه ايضا
وعدد من قاده الاجهزه الامنيه هنا ووزاره
الداخليه
والدفاع المدني ايضا وارى اليات كبيره لا
حسره لها من تابعه لجهاز الدفاع المدني
سيارات الاسعاف بالتاكيد تقوم باعمال في
هذا المكان يبدو ان بعض سيارات الاسعاف في
الاخرى ما زالت في المكان لكن همم يعني
نحن لا نستطيع لا نشاهد سيارات تنقل همم
ربما جرحى او فيات من داخل المنزل كما
يبدو بانهم اهتموا عمليه اجلاء او انتشال
الجثامين والجرحى من داخل المنزل لكن كما
يبدو بانهم يحاولون همم وضع المساحه على
الاحصائيه النهائيه سواء في عدد الوفيات
او عدد الجرحى وكذلك الاضرار التي لمت
بهذا المنزل فضلا والاهم من ذلك عن
الاسباب السبب الحقيقي والمباشر لعمليه
اندلاع هذا الحريق في هذا المنزل على هذا
النحو وعلى هذه الصوره المفجعه التي اتت
على كامل المنزل بشكل كبير وايضا ادت الى
هذه النتيجه الكارثيه التي لم تتكرر في
قطاع غزه السوى مرات محدوده جدا قبل عده
سنوات كان هناك حريق في منطقه الوسطى
وبالتحديد في سوق همم بالنصيرات وسط قطاع
غزه ايضا اتت النيران على عدد من المحال
التجاريه لكن همم
تتحول ان يتحول هذا المنزل الى همم يعني
همم
نيران بهذا الشكل السريع والمفاجئ وان
يتفحم ويقع كل افراد المنزل ما بين قتيل
وجريح هذا يعتبر همم حقيقه محل تساؤل كبير
همم وهذا وهاء اجابات هذه التساؤلات
بالتاكيد امام الجهات
هذه الاجابات
المعلومات
الحدث الجديد والكثير الكثير من همم يعني
الاصداء والتعاطف مع اهالي الضحايا لكن
كيف
السبب الذي ادى الى حدوث هذا الحريق ذكرت
في البدايه انه ال- ال-
نعم
احتفالده حقيقه حول حول السبب الرئيسي
فيما يتعلق باندلاع هذا الحريق لكن
بالتاكيد الروايه النهائيه والدقيقه هي
لدى جهات الاختصاص نحاول ان نستطلع بعض
هذه او بعض تفاصيل هذه الروايه لدى قائد
الشرطه الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه يعطيك
العافيه
لو طبعنا في سوره المدثر يعني في حريق في
الطابق الثالث في بنايه سكنيه مكونه من
ثلاث طوابق همم يوجد عدد من الوفيات همم
طواقم الشرطه والدفاع المدني ادله جنائيه
همم
والبحث الجنائي اضافه الى تحقيق الدفاع
المدني الجميع يعمل في المكان
لمعرفه اسباب الحريق والسبب المباشر من
وجهه نظرك حتى الان لا يوجد همم سبب
نهائي واضح نعلن عنه طواق التحقيق في
الدفاع المدني وفي الشرطه تعمل في المكان
للوصول الى الاسباب النهائيه للحريق
النتيجه النهائيه النتيجه النهائيه انه
حتى الان الطواقي ما زالت تعمل
عدد الوفيات او الجر عدد الوفيات حتى الان
ااا لم يتم الاعلان عن عدد الوفيات لكن
نتحدث عن اكثر من 10 فيها
للاسف لا حول الاسباب ولا حول عدد الوفيات